notre série avoir 20 ans dans les années
2020 on fait la connaissance aujourd'hui
des lisa elle est factrice à liernais en
côte d'or bamba guèye et rodolphe logis
ont passé la journée avec elle
c'est dur d'avoir un temps de
maintenance
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle heather haddock
j'ai 23 ans je travail à la poste de
lire né en côte d'or et j'habite
arconcey pas très loin d'ici
[Musique]
lâchés en train de trier montreuil et
dans l'ordre de ma tournée
je crie dans le lent pour qu'une fan mon
courrier au fur et à mesure des clients
c'est plus soif a perdu quoi
ça doit être ma voisine
moi je peux pas être
enfermé toute la journée dans un bureau
derrière mon ordi ou à voir personne il
faut que j'ai un métier qui bouge que je
vois du monde du coup c'est ça me
correspond parfaitement
à lever un beau
jeune elle a des super capacités pour
être une excellente actrice donc elle
est agréable et les réserves elle est
souriante
elle un bon contact avec les clients
même avec le bureau avec ses collègues
bon bah voilà j'ai fini de charger ma
voiture mes colis sont triés mon
courrier là et je pars en tournée
[Musique]
j'ai pas eu mon bac 2 fois et j'étais
pas trop fait pour les études je pense
et donc j'ai commencé à faire des petits
boulots en intérim
et j'ai fait plein de trucs dans l'art
et dans la restauration avec les enfants
avec les personnes âgées
et puis et puis après voilà je suis
rentré à la poste et ça fait un an et
demi que j'y suis moi
alors
votre courrier ouais et puis le fameux
recommandons je quitte pas son os quoi
gentil
oui très gentil elle montre mon courrier
ça va
comme je peux pas monter mais deschamps
d'escalier ça va
un petit gâteau va
ça va oui fraîchement sacré bon quand il
ya un petit vent qui est fréquent ben
oui mais c'est voir le facteur à tous
les jours ça c'est important pour moi je
suis tout seul et puis comme on n'est
pas beaucoup alors je veux mon vous même
faire la peau ce que je ne veux pas que
ce soit quelqu'un qui me met dans la
boîte pour je veux voir le facteur voilà
des fois on peut tomber on est tout seul
un facteur israël voit que c'est vrai
c'est important vous rassure ça me
rassure à deux journées mais il ya des
personnes la seule personne qu'elle voit
de toute la journée c'est le facteur et
des fois j'ai des clients je m'arrête
même si j'ai pas de courrier je m'arrête
leur dire bonjour leur demander si ça va
parce que c'était personnes qui habitent
tout seul des fois un peu isolée donc ça
reste un lien quand même le facteur
des avantages déjà c'est les horaires
parce que je dirais en général à trois
heures et demie je suis chez moi donc
j'ai le temps de faire plein de choses
l'après midi
dans un temps peut-être toujours à la
poste mais peut-être plus factrice
peut-être
monter en grade au dessus ou où je sais
pas il peut se passer tellement de trucs
en 20 ans que c'est difficile de dire ce
que je me vois